ever wonder how zombie edible brains are
made oh we got the recipe from the
makers of resident evil retribution and
today we're going to show you how to
make time so here's where you're going
to need 14 tablespoons of glycerin 14
tablespoons of sorbitol 7 tablespoons of
gelatin one-half teaspoon zinc oxide
water is needed and a few drops of food
coloring oh and you're also going to
need a brain vault first we're going to
take the glycerin put in the bowl now
we're going to add the sorbitol
next we're going to add the gelatin now
we're going to add the zinc oxide and we
mix it all together so now we're going
to take our mixture and put in the
microwave for two minutes until the
powder melts into the liquid and there
are no lumps if your mixture isn't fully
blended after two minutes you may want
to put it in the microwave for another
two minutes mmm smells delicious now we
want to mix our mixture together until
it's fully blended the next step is to
add a little bit of water so your brains
aren't too hard and finally we're going
to add a few drops of food coloring one
drop of red one drop of green and one
drop of blue will produce a nice grey
brain
bear in mind this is completely edible
the kids are going to love this now that
our mixture is done we're going to pour
it into the brain mold and let it set
for a couple of hours
after it sets you'll have a fresh brain
like the one I made earlier boys dinner
can't wish me I can't believe you in my
room my train set you know what if you
wanted to come in through right through
my record you know maybe you want to go
down those are like all white keys at
school for our records dude dude
seriously oh we catch FS come on you you
are the reason why people look at us
like we're monsters you know just wrong
with a man can't deal with she's on Bob